[Musique]
la palme d'or décernée à part asic de
bong joon ho a couronné pour la première
fois le cinéma sud coréen à travers l'un
de ses auteurs les plus emblématiques
ah oui absolument avec park chan wook
c'est ça fait partie des deux cinéastes
coréens qui savent mêler cinéma d'auteur
et cimade genre et bong joon-ho il a
réinventé le polar coréen au début des
années 2000 avec memories of murder qui
était adaptée d'un fait réel et il a
fait ce film absolument extraordinaire
qu'on se lasse pas de revoir et qu'il a
posé immédiatement sur le devant de la
scène tout de suite on a découvert un
auteur et après il a décliné c'était
formidable je veux dire il à elle quand
il a décliné sa palette
c'est the host avec la créature
aquatique c'est mother et cette histoire
de tueur et de demers qui essayent
d'innocenter son fils et puis après il a
été à l'international c'est l'adaptation
de la bd snow pierceur et puis ces
objets l'histoire des cochons mutants
qui avait tant à nous dire sur ma
l'agriculture biologique et voilà et là
il revient à sa base et c'est ça qui est
très fort en cela il revient affirme
purement coréen et cette triple base qui
est la sienne à savoir ambitions de mise
en scène profondeur sociales et
politiques du scénario et cet humour
absolument fausses c'est que vous allez
nous montrer quelques images mon cher
film et bab celui banques c'est-à-dire
que vous souvenez au moment de cannes on
vous a montré la scène du début avec ce
formidable travelling descendants où on
allait comme ça a soupiré alors
l'extrait que je vous proposais ben on y
est là dont on y est dans la soupe
antonier avec cette famille pauvre
dans cet espace très réduit et regarder
comment cet espace et fermez là on a le
père et il est coincé entre le mur et la
table 1 il faut savoir que bong joon ho
a fait des storyboards très précis qu'il
a donné à son décorateur et les acteurs
ils sont placés à la marque regarder ce
couloir regarder ll est à laver il n'y a
aucune place
l'espace est complètement mangés par les
objets larchitecture donc les acteurs la
regarder à ses pieds il a sa mère vers
que non seulement il a il a un couloir
très reste un dans le cadre mais même en
basse et s'est complètement j'ai donc
c'est à dire que c'est un territoire
très petit bourg et de choses bourré de
gens évidemment il faut s'en extraire et
pour exemple on va s'élever alors
regarder la caméra elle est au dessus et
il nous rejoint 1 et 2 fois on va voir
ça le panoramique
c'est à dire qu'il ya toujours quelque
chose à côté et à côté quoi il ya cette
ouverture
on sort de ce couloir et tout d'un coup
il va vers la lumière
il va dans le sol et regardez comme
c'est pure et là encore on l'attend au
il va y monte on profite bien de sa
montée les murs sont presque vierge qui
égayaient de là enfin il ya de la nature
ya de la verdure
c'est magnifique sauf que là tout à coup
regardez la contre-plongée à attention
attention attention là il est devant ce
code c'est à dire que tout à coup il
faut avoir le code pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir jaser et c'est peut-être pas si
facile que ça et regardez la porte qui
s'ouvre la porte et cette espèce de truc
mécanique et derrière qu'est ce qu'on
voit encore les la végétation fait comme
encore des départs aux arcs
attention ça s'ouvre il ya de la verdure
mais va falloir se battre
on est au début du film et on est
prévenu palme d'or à l'unanimité
critique festivalière en admiration
public en émoi on peut se demander quand
même s'il ya des anti parasites au
hasard pluriel bonsoir
non mais c'est une palme d'or qui n'est
pas volée c'était extrêmement dur
on sent se laisse vraiment qui est au
sommet de son art qui est extrêmement à
l'aise avec ce film tellement à l'aise
qui peut faire de l'humour et c'est très
jouissif à voir là où agen preuve c'est
que parfois la virtuosité me mets à
distance parce que c'est une machine
presque parfaite et une cathédrale
scénaristique aussi tellement complexes
qu'on est quand même obligé d'avaler
certaines invraisemblances qui moi me
gêne un peu et sur le terrain de la
métaphore politique j'avoue que moi j'ai
vu une sorte de chabrol version cartoon
et chabrol
à chaque fois son kart ou sur la pelouse
des rouages en ce sens la distance est
une forme d'objectivité un peu cruel
comme il en est comme il existe chez
chabrol et chez clouzot moi je trouve
que ce qui est fascinant sextant vrais
peintres du social et comme tu le disais
phillips et qu'en plus d'être un
cinéaste voilà de la société des
rapports violents très rugueux entre
entre ces différentes classes mais c'est
aussi un grand cinéaste grande grands
virtuoses du cinéma qui s'est joué des
lignes qui sait jouer des dimensions et
ça c'est qu'il faut pour rappeler
l'histoire quand même de deux parasites
marie l'histoire assez drôle parce que
ça démarre un petit peu comme démarrer
la palme d'or du corps et et dallas
l'année dernière vous vous souvenez on
est au sein d'une famille dont qui vit
dans un endroit minuscule qui galèrent
avec des micros jobs nul de pliage de
piles de boîtes de pizza enfin vraiment
et tout à coup l'idée d'une arnaque
voilà et donc c'est une famille qui va
devenir le parasite d'une famille
extrêmement riche qui vit dans une
maison un sens et dessiné par un
architecte
voilà la maison dans laquelle on
pénétrait à l'instant et ce qui est
assez passionnant c'est la méchanceté du
film je trouve que vraiment ça ça me
vois pas ce que parce qu'on rit
énormément même temps c'est d'une
cruauté folle et je dirais que si je
devais faire une demi heure c'est un
mythe que ces micro réserve est vraiment
une demie c'est que l'empathie qu'on a
immédiatement pour la famille pauvre on
ne l'aura jamais pour son pendant
riesch qui est en moi ce que je veux
c'est me collard et que marie tu dis et
le titre dits parasites c'est évidemment
ce mécanisme de parasitisme de cette
famille pauvre sur cette famille riche
mais en fait c'est surtout un grand film
politique qu'il faut vraiment vois tu
dois dire que les bras les vrais
parasites de la société
c'est évidemment la famille et surtout
ce qui il riche la famille riche
évidemment et ce qui est formidable
c'est que en fait sans rien dévoiler du
film c'est un film d'une noirceur totale
l'impasse sociale et complète la seule
solution c'est la relégation sociale
parce que il n'y a pas qu'une famille
parasitaires et le seul moyen de
survivre
c'est en parasitant cette société de la
consommation et c'est un film hyper
sociologiquement parlant pointu
bourdieusien presque et je rajoute un
truc c'est que ça pourrait faire peur de
dire des mots comme elle mais la semaine
dernière quand je les ai vus
au cinéma je suis allé dans un grand
multiplex qui en général est vide à ces
heures là
la salle était complète serre que c'est
un vrai film populaire qui parle
absolument à tout le monde et dont le
message politique porte et ça c'est
quand même extrêmement exceptionnel il
rassemble aussi parce que c'est un film
multi genres c'est un polar c'est un
revenge movie c'est une comédie noire
c'est un drame familial est féroce en
voilà il ya aussi ça et c'était
extrêmement bien excités attaquent à
tiroirs mairie de bong joon ho aussi les
clubs de faire ceci est extrêmement
exigeant et éminemment populaire tous
ses films précédents sur les grands
films populaires et ben c'est ça c'est
ce que je vous disais c'est que il va
chercher dans les gens c'est un grand
raconteur d'histoires et nous intéresse
aux personnages et moi je suis pas
d'accord avec toi quand tu dis qu'on n'a
pas d'empathie pour les pour la famille
riesch 1 parce que moi le dire ils sont
très très intéressant il n'est pas dit
qu'ils n'étaient pas intéressants j'ai
dit qu'on sait tout de suite vers qui le
coeur du cinéma
equi le coeur du cinéma j'aime beaucoup
le monsieur parc qui avec avec son idée
de refuser des gens qui dépassent les
limites et lui passe son temps à ça
héhéhé
je veux dire il ya comme une sorte de
complicité sont des mauvaises odeurs
quelque chose me leurs vieux grotesque
cercueil a effectivement marie a raison
il ya aucun moment où d'un seul coup
nous en tant que spectateur on va
s'identifier à eux eux ils sont là
vraiment comme un archétype justement du
foot et ce qui permet aussi de la
comédie si les émissaires des rires
c'est un film - hurle de rire
c'est là où c'est absolument génial
c'est à dire que ont eu un rôle de rire
pendant un bon moment et tout à coup
alors que on dira jamais dans quoi
jamais donc mais je veux dire que cette
rupture de ton ses trouvailles en
permanence voilà les spectateurs qui
vont ils vont se régaler il ya une
histoire de pêche
on va rien dire sur l'histoire de pêche
mais c'est une trouvaille géniale
il ya dans ces décors tu parlais du sens
des décors qui est inouï dans le film
mais il ya par exemple un type il dit
dans un entresol il ya un type qui vient
pisser devant chez eux tous les jours
c'est cette toile est en fête et
l'histoire d'odeurs dans le film qui
revient et qui est le truc le plus
violent qu'on verra ou peut-être au
cinéma cette année
en fait on ne sait plus où donner de la
tête a mûri à messac il ya un côté
chabrol augmenté chabrol de 2000
19 avec cette même mali ce qu'avait
chabrol il a un peu dédié son film à
chabrol dire chabrol lors d'une
cérémonie de clôture du festival de
cannes coincé voilà c'est sur 5 parce
que je trouve ça hyper beau qu'un signal
commun se réclame de chabrol 0,4 y fiez
pas forcément celui qu'on retient de la
nouvelle vague et qui pourra peut-être
le plus grand c'est la nouvelle matin
philippe d'or chabrol tu rigoles avec
rohmer dans l'abattoir on ne peut pas
savoir lesquels sont sur les meilleurs
mais l'autre l'autre c'est évidemment la
saison oui on parle le film de kinki
août 2009 160 ha il nous manquait sur la
wii mais c'est le chef-d'oeuvre du ceba
corps et alain servante et et le film se
nourrit de la évidemment nous il ya ça à
peu les cinéphiles qui le connaissent
mais encore et c'est le film qui est
connu comme les enfants du paradis si
vous voulez et et on a déjà cette idée
de ba de la servante qui s'introduit et
récite domesticité et de l'escalier
l'icône mode la pression'' en aussi pour
rebondir sur ce que disait muriel tout à
l'heure c'est effectivement si un film
qui est impressionnant par sa maîtrise
formelle et notamment par sa rythmique
par son tempo et par ce montage serre
qu'il n'y a pas une once de temps mort
il ya vraiment une espèce de danse
d'enchaînement des séquences d'un genre
à l'autre etc qui fait que 2h11
on ressort de là on a l'impression
d'avoir un est rentré il ya les minutes
dans les salles écrit mais l'écriture au
cordeau c'est une vraie très très belle
palme d'or parasites de bong joon ho
vous êtes donc au cinéma vous avez
compris un courez le voir